bonjour à tous les deux merci beaucoup
d'être en direct ce magnifique sur rt
france on l'a vu l'allemagne veut
imposer la vaccination obligatoire après
un vote au parlement ça devrait entrer
en vigueur en février ou en mars
écoutez le futur chancelier
je suggère que les députés fassent une
proposition de loi au parlement
est ce que c'est un exemple à suivre
selon vous s'il ya noël
côté pour moi imposer la vaccine subi
gâteau ça signifie avant tout l'échec
des politiques publiques qui sont à
nouveau
tenue de contraindre plutôt que de
convaincre et ça signifierait donc une
grave crise de confiance entre ces
gouvernements et leurs peuples notamment
en matière médicale monde c'est le
consentement libre et éclairé est une
notion fondamentale les arts le seul
qu'elle est quel est votre sentiment
à écouter pour être très très honnête
nous avons au sein du groupe socialiste
à l'assemblée nationale comme au sénat
déjà réfléchi discuté de cette
obligation vaccinale c'est une
proposition qui avait été envisagé dès
cet été c'est une proposition qui a été
discuté au sénat au mois d'octobre
si la situation
comment dire je dramatise ou si la
situation
empire une faudra effectivement
envisager une obligation vaccinale de
toute façon ce qui a été mise en place
par le gouvernement sans le dire avec le
pass sanitaire revient à une obligation
vaccinale c'est un peu la même chose je
vous la corde l'obligation vaccinale
pourtant et n'est pas le choix de la
france a dit olivier ferrand pour lui
c'est possible de le faire pour les
enfants mais pas pour les adultes
regardent et
qui dit obligation d'y contrôler
sanction donc la faisabilité n'est pas
évidente on sait faire une obligation
vaccinale chez les tout petits chez les
nourrissons chez les adultes c'est plus
compliqué je ne dis pas que c'est
impossible
voilà ces arguments s'il ya de noël est
ce qu'ils sont tenables ses arguments on
peut le faire pour les enfants mais pas
pour les adieux pourquoi
écoutez là aussi je m'interroge quand
même au bout de deux ans d'épidémie je
pense qu'on a suffisamment de recul sur
ce virus aujourd'hui pour savoir quels
sont les publics véritablement du
vénérable or les jeunes et les enfants
sont clairement des publics qui sont
extrêmement peu concerné par le virus
donc aujourd'hui pourquoi vouloir faire
peser sur ces classes d'âge une
vaccination dont on sait très bien le
rapport bénéfices risques est loin
d'être favorable à la vaccination
pourquoi vouloir faire aboutir à une
espèce d'immunité collective
qui est le purement
factuel et presque hypothétique en
faisant peser cette vaccination sur des
classes d'âgés des catégories de
population qui ne sont pas vraiment
conservé par le virus avant l'apparition
des vaccins est exactement avant avant
de parution du vaccin il faut se
souvenir qu'on ne parlait que d'immunité
naturelle
il n'y a vait ça qui compte elle il
fallait presque que les gens
attrapent ce biais pour ensuite être
bénéficier de cette immunité naturelle
dont on sait tous et même les
scientifiques en cours viennent
quelle est la plus durable et la plus
efficace dans tous les enfants sont
atteints apparemment assez massivement
donc a priori il sera immunisé
évidemment évidemment on pourra bien lui
l'union européenne doit doit réfléchir à
la vaccination obligatoire c'est ce qu'a
déclaré hier ursula von der leyen la
présidente de l'union européenne écouter
il est approprié et raisonnable d'avoir
cette discussion maintenant c'est ma
position personnelle cela nécessite une
approche commune mais je pense que c'est
une discussion qui doit avoir lieu un
gérard le seul donc vous êtes favorable
à la vaccination obligatoire l'europe
tend vers vers cela ça devrait être
débattue c'est vrai qu'une vaccination
obligatoire au niveau d'un état n'a pas
beaucoup de sens il faudrait même
l'appliquer au niveau de monde elle
selon vous
écoutez très clairement c'est comme la
vaccination de la deux sens que si tout
le monde se met progressivement à
vacciner ses ressortissants donc c'est
la même démarche que l choix obligatoire
qui ne soit pas obligatoire à partir du
moment où tout le monde s'accorde à dire
qu'il faut une immunité collective qui
passe par la vaccination donc il ne faut
pas jouer sur les mots je pense
qu'aujourd'hui la question est
réellement et sérieusement posée
d'accroître encore la vaccination et de
la rendre obligatoire d'auxerre dans une
discussion effectivement européenne
parce que ça a du sens parce que nous
construisons une europe maintenant c'est
une chanson des mesures qui peuvent être
prises bien sûr au niveau de chaque pays
car chaque pays est souverain toujours
sa politique sanitaire
bien sûr bien sûr mais pour revenir sur
ce que disait notre collègue sénatrice
la situation peut évoluer la
connaissance que nous avons évolué
compris parce que les virus mutent dont
il n'est pas absurde de dire ce que nous
n'avons pas fait hier nous pouvons le
faire demain je suis extrêmement
favorable et je m'étais exprimé au titre
d'un rapport que nous avions remis de
l'office parlementaire d'évaluation des
choix scientifiques et technologiques en
décembre dernier à l'assemblée nationale
pour convaincre convaincre convaincre
convaincre cependant face aujourd'hui à
une recrudescence giram est un virus qui
risque d'être plus mortels il n'est pas
inenvisageable de changer de méthode
c'est vrai que tout le monde a été pris
de court par ce variant omicron en fait
le fait d'avoir une couverture vaccinale
satisfaisante ça empêcherait également
lé virus de muter donc
ne serait-il pas temps d'agir sylviane
noël
oui enfin on voit surtout aujourd'hui
que la plupart des vaccins disponibles
ne sont efficaces qu'à hauteur de 40%
sur le virus le verlan d'état donc on
peut quand même s'interroger sur la
réelle
efficacité
d'un d'une vaccination massive pour
essayer d'enrayer l'épidémie faut quand
même rappeler que l'outil et d'arômes le
vaccin qui est un outil au mieux qui
empêche les formes graves et c'est déjà
très bien mais en ce qui concerne la
transmission du virus
plusieurs études ont montré que les
vaccinés était quasiment autant facteur
de contagiosité que les points dax ine
donc pourquoi vouloir aller absolument
vers une stratégie de vaccination
massive concentrons-nous avant tout sur
des publics fragiles
à risque qu'on identifie maintenant
parfaitement bien avec deux années de
recul
et puis concernant le variant ou micron
avec le temps là on a vu plusieurs
études surgir et notamment les sud
africains dans lequel se mariant aînés
qui nous disent qu'il n'est pas si
terrible que cela il a pas l'air en tout
cas très l'état donc
arrêtons de vouloir faire monter cette
peur irrationnelle attendons de voir
avant d'agir enfin moi je suis toujours
dit la même entre eux prévoir et
attendre on reproche souvent de manquer
d'anticipation et ensuite de prendre des
mesures trop anticipé oui enfin là on
est quand même en ont mais on habite
aujourd'hui en france dans un pays où on
sert du principe de précaution à toutes
les sauces et je suis quand même très
surprise de voir que on n'applique pas
ce même principe à la vaccination qui
n'est pas un geste anodin et notamment
sur des publics encore une fois je le
rappelle qu'ils ne sont pas
ils m'aiment pour les derniers variant
qui sont apparus forcément vulnérable à
ces virus donc attention mais c'est rare
le sale c'est vrai l'om est dit que pour
l'instant il n'y a que des formes
légères qui sont provoquées par ce
nouveau variant omicron est ce qu'on
n'en fait pas beaucoup finalement
dès qu'un nouveau variant va arriver ce
sera fermeture des frontières
incitation à sers vacciner pour une
quatrième dose écoutez je ne peux pas
partager le discours de notre collègue
sénatrice c'est totalement irresponsable
elle de manière relativement soft elle
met complètement en cause l'intérêt de
la vaccination c'est déraisonnable nous
savons l'ensemble de la communauté
scientifique considère et à juste raison
qu'il est nécessaire d'avoir une
vaccination donc je ne comprends pas
pourquoi de manière insidieuse on
considère que le vaccin finalement ne
serait pas suffisant insuffisamment
évidemment couvrant et aidera il faut
aujourd'hui les six personnes trois îles
mais il faut écouter l'ensemble de la
communauté scientifique y compris la
communauté scientifique nationale et
internationale qui recommande une
vaccination parce que la vaccination
permet d'enrayer la circulation du virus
je pense que c'est un discours
responsable que de dire ça et c'est pas
responsable de dire que ça ne couvre pas
suffisamment alors pour le médecin
martin blachier la stratégie vaccinale
doit être centré sur les personnes les
plus fragiles ac c'est d'ailleurs comme
la la la stratégie de vaccination contre
la grippe écoutez le
vélo horie la stratégie vaccinale que
vide doit converger vers la stratégie
vaccinale grippale voilà ce qu'il a dit
centrées sur les personnes à risque pour
les protéger et préserver les services
hospitaliers dans la bienveillance et la
sérénité c'est vrai qu'il ya un vrai
débat sur qui ciblé par rapport à cette
vaccination la grèce notamment
l'imposent pour les personnes les plus
fragiles les plus de 60 ans notamment
voyez ce qu'on a dit le le premier
ministre grec
jeu de 500000 grecque âgés de plus de 60
on refuse toujours la vaccination
arrivant souvent à l'hôpital et
entravant le traitement d'autres
maladies graves alors c'est compliqué de
dire qu'ils arrivent à l'hôpital on n'a
pas beaucoup d'infos finalement
là-dessus sylviane noël on entendait
tout à l'heure ce médecin allemand dans
notre édition nous dire qu'il y avait
aussi des jeunes c'est c'est compliqué
de dire qui finalement est véritablement
touché par par ce virus est ce que pour
vous la stratégie grecque est la bonne
probablement je ne sais pas moi je en
tout cas ce que ce ce que je remet en
doute
chef collègues ce n'est pas l'efficacité
des vaccins encore une fois ces vaccins
sont utiles pour éviter des formes
graves chez les sujets fragiles porteurs
de comorbidité c'est une évidence
mais sur des sujets qui ont une immunité
naturelle qui leur permet de ne pas être
exposés au virus
l'a5 aux questions
on va venir à ce qu'a dit au ministre d
outre mer il a accordé une exception aux
antilles après les protestations
sébastien lecornu qui a promis une
adaptation de l'obligation vaccinale
regarder une loi votée s'applique sur
l'ensemble des territoires de la
république dont le département de la
martinique ou de la guadeloupe en
revanche il faut l'appliquer cette loi
est ce que l'application peut être
adapté sur la base de la loi
j'ai indiqué que le principe de réalité
sociale et sanitaire s'imposerait à tous
les partenaires évidemment l'obligation
vaccinale pour les soignants gérard le
sol
où est le principe d'égalité finalement
voilà c'est un principe de réalité face
à des tensions sociales extrêmement vive
et on sait pourquoi globalement
les antilles sont assez réfractaire et
notamment à cause du chlordécone et
d'une parole de l'état qui a été ajustée
à juste raison le contester maintenant
il semble indispensable effectivement
pour nos amis d'autres maires de pouvoir
être vacciné le plus rapidement possible
le gouvernement ne souhaitant pas de
tension sociale
impose finalement la vaccination est
diffèrent dans le temps je trouve pas ça
très courageux mais c'est la position du
gouvernement aujourd'hui ainsi il ya
noël quel est votre sentiment sur sur ce
sursis en tout cas accordé à la
vaccination obligatoire pour les
soignants aux antilles
mais moi je le trouve bien venu
j'aimerais que les soignants de
métropole puissent également bénéficier
j'ai toujours considéré comme
profondément injuste le traitement qui
était réservé aux soignants et puis ou
plus largement on compte y est enfin
prêt toutes ces catégories tous ces
soldats dont on a besoin normalement en
temps de guerre et dont on se passe
aujourd'hui donc on n'a pas hésité à
abattre à mettre de côté sans revenu
sans statut voilà ça m'interpelle
beaucoup de voir des soignants des gens
responsables faut pas oublier qu'il y à
il ya dix huit mois de cela ces mêmes
personnes allaient travailler dans les
hôpitaux sans nous sans branches sans
masque sans gel hydroalcoolique parfois
porteurs de la maladie on leur disait
que même s'il était malade il pouvait
aller travailler et aujourd'hui ils sont
pointés du doigt ils sont quasiment
traité d'irresponsable mans ça me chante
beaucoup alors qu'on sait très bien
encore une fois que le vaccin ne permet
pas d'assurer
une absence de contagiosité les
personnes non vaccinées sont possibles
sont parmi les personnes vaccinées sont
aussi contaminantes quelque part que les
personnes vaccinées la seule pardon
surtout que l'argument invoqué par par
ces soignants en martinique c'est qu'il
ya engorgement et et ne plus pouvoir
faire face à l'accueil des malades dans
les hôpitaux la question à se poser
peut-être en france également mais elle
se pose déjà
on a eu un cas là très récemment en
france là le 1er novembre d'une de d'un
patient qui n'a pas pu être opérés
attendant faute d'un médecin réanimateur
les services pédiatriques sont
complètement engorgé aujourd'hui on a
quinze mille patients qui se répètent
15000 personnel soignant qui sont
suspendus écoutez on est en période
épidémique
nos hôpitaux nos hôpitaux sont déjà à
l'os et on se permet de se passer de 15
me soigne à
une réaction gérard le sol
oui c'est un propos démagogiques
je pense qu'il n'est pas responsable de
dire fla il n'est pas responsable de
dire qu'une personne vaccinée n'est pas
finalement suffi d'un mobilisés et que
ça ne permet pas d'enrayer
progressivement la circulation du virus
et donc je considère que je propose est
démagogique de la même manière je
considère que l'ensemble du personnel
soignant qui est en proximité de
personnel fragiles d'être vaccinés alors
la question les enfants il nous reste
quelques minutes la question de la
vaccination des enfants de 5 à 11 ans
elle a été encouragée par la haute
autorité de santé pour au moins trois
cent soixante mille enfants à risque
voyez ce qu'on a dit le ministre de la
santé
si nous entamions une campagne de
vaccination ouverte aux enfants de 5 à
11 ans se serait en début d'année 2022
gérard le seul on va y venir à cette
vaccination pour les enfants on a
toujours entendu le gouvernement dire on
va pas le faire et finalement il le fait
écoutez ça fait six mois qu'ils
effectivement je pense et je dis qu on y
viendra très certainement parce
qu'effectivement nous n'arrivons pas
aujourd'hui avec la couverture vaccinale
à enrayer complètement de virus et demi
à enrayer les nouveaux virus arrivants
et donc il fait effectivement il faut se
poser très sérieusement la question de
la vaccination des enfants et de la même
manière qu'il ya eu une stratégie
vaccinale à destination des personnels
de plus des personnes de plus de 60 ans
fragile eh bien c'est la même stratégie
qui devra s'appliquer si les décider si
globalement les autorités médicales et
scientifiques considèrent qu' il n'y a
pas de risque à vacciner les enfants il
faudra effectivement appliqué la même
stratégie c'est à dire on commence par
les plus risqués et le mot de la fin ce
sera pour vous s'il ya noël pour ou
contre la vaccination pour les enfants
de 5 à 11 ans
on va compter évidemment je compte tenu
de tout ce que j'ai développé
précédemment je vous le redis pour moi
la vaccination elle doit avant tout ceci
être ciblées sur les personnes les plus
à risque les portes de cornaux bilité ne
faisons pas porter une recherche
hypothétique de pseudo immunité
collective sur nos enfants sur sur ceux
qui ne sont pas ciblés un vaccin ce
n'est jamais quelque chose d'anodin donc
l'immunité naturelle doit être
privilégiée dans ce genre de pia et puis
je me permettent quand même de répondre
à mon collègue qui me traitent de
démagogique ce n'est pas moi qui affirme
que les non vaccinés sont aussi enfin
son sont pas plus contaminant que les
vacciner c'est une étude de l'impérial
collège de londres et d'autres études
qui le met en évidence donc
arrêtons arrêtons d'opposer et de cliver
les gens
revenons un peu plus de rationalité et
moins de peur dans traitement de cette
crise et je pense qu'on ne s'en sortira
pas plus mal merci beaucoup c'était le
mot de la fin merci beaucoup à tous les
deux merci gérard le sol et merci à vous
sylviane noël d'avoir un débattue ce
matin en direct sur arte france
[Musique]